so this is a residential area of a
suburban town in Massachusetts and if
you look on my right you will actually
see that there are nicely paved
sidewalks but we know from what we just
talked about for the built environment
and walkability access and availability
of sidewalks isn't the only thing that
determines walkability other factors
that influence walkability include mixed
land use and proximity to common
destinations such as grocery stores and
banks and so for here while there are
sidewalks available it is primarily
residential and so there are no other
places that you can get to via walking
in terms of combinations so thinking
back to what we talked about in terms of
street connectivity I'm about to pull
into a cul-de-sac which is essentially
in the street again there are sidewalks
available but you'll see that very few
people are actually walking around
and there's only one main road in order
to get from various houses to other
places
so it would be a lot faster to drive to
one house on this particular loop than
walking from one house to another
so here you see is where the loop occurs
and it's essentially it didn't
all right now we're back headed back to
the main road
so here we are headed into a large
shopping centre and this is actually
pretty typical of a lot of places in the
United States particularly in suburban
or rural areas there are lots of
different restaurants and stores around
including grocery stores banks clothing
stores you can see that the parking lots
are actually incredibly expansive so the
stores lined the perimeter but in terms
of the parking spaces available there's
no shortage of parking around here and
even though all of the different stores
are pretty walkable you can walk from
for example the grocery store to a pet
store or a sandwich stop across the
street nobody is walking around
everybody is driving so somewhere in the
shopping center are all the people who
came in these cars but we actually don't
see them at all except going to and from
their cars
in this area you'll see that the street
planning and urban design is actually
much more friendly to walkers and bikers
than it is for drivers as evidenced by
the multiple crosswalks and the ample
sidewalk space for pedestrians and the
bikers so when we think about
walkability we usually think about how
conducive an area is to walking but
biking is another way in which we can be
physically active and still get from
place to place on the left here we have
some hub way bikes which you can rent
for about six dollars for a 24-hour
period behind me you can see that
there's mixed land use a mix of
commercial shops for the most part but
there are also apartment buildings that
are located behind the shops so this is
an area where you can see that there's a
good quality of land mixed-use both
residential and commercial welcome back
I hope you enjoyed the tour you've seen
different characteristics of the built
environment and the food environment in
different areas in Massachusetts but you
might also be wondering what are some of
the other characteristics of
neighborhoods around the US and around
the world for this online activity you
can explore two different websites to
get a sense of how different
neighborhoods are within the US as well
as in other countries the first website
is Walk Score calm walk score calm
provides an index of walkability ranging
from zero to 100 100 being the highest
they provide this information using
online and iOS services the second
website that you can visit is the US
Department of Agriculture food
environment Atlas this particular
website provides a map of the US and
although you can't enter in addresses
you can click on different areas on the
map to get a sense about differences
between neighborhoods and access and
proximity of grocery stores the USDA
food environment Atlas also provides
information about food deserts in
particular areas in the United States